we are getting new insight tonight into
the teenager accused in last winter's
Parkland High School massacre in South
Florida and it is disturbing
correspondent Phil Keating shows us from
Miami for the first time we see Nicholas
Cruz breaking down and pretending to
kill himself inside the Broward County
interrogation room just three hours
after being arrested not far from
Stoneman Douglas high after the
Valentine's Day Massacre which killed 17
and wounded 17 more shortly before the
detective enters the room Cruz punches
himself in the face over and over
he eventually explains to the detective
why he did what he did the voice the
demon inside his head at another point
during the session the detective steps
out of the room and Cruz bites his
forearm trying to bleed Cruz also makes
a gun with his fingers pulling the
trigger to his head mouth and heart the
portion of the interview where Cruz
allegedly gave a step-by-step account of
how he carried out the worst high school
shooting in US history remains redacted
and edited out to protect Cruz's right
to a fair trial Cruz's 18 year old
brother Zachary is led in around
midnight and that's when Cruz shakes and
sobs in his arms Cruz also reveals he'd
attempted suicide twice how lonely he
was and depressed over his mother's
recent death throughout the 12-hour
interview the detective keeps zeroing
back in on this so-called demon Cruz
never budges
like today my life crews also says he
planned to go to a public park the week
before to shoot a bunch of innocent
people there but backed out his defense
team still offers to plead guilty to
everything to avoid the possibility of
the death penalty but the prosecutor is
not taking it Mike
Phil Keating in Miami thank you